Hello everyone, this is Dr. Conner's again and welcome to module six of this stop fighting cancer course
So this one is about
Cleared up the environment
We always just think of environment like
Our yard or the
Environment in our neighborhood. We're really talking about the environment in your body of course
Cleared up the environment to your house. We could have an entire module on that
Maybe we'll have to have that a somewhat you all about
Making sure that you're not using chemicals and things in your cleaners
That's not what we're going to really talk about here. We're talking about your body here. So
Really when we're understanding a cleated environment, we're talking about
Terrain theory. That's one word for it
We used to call it that your balloon
Your balloon is how your cells are functioning or dysfunctioning is in part to their environment the balloon the terrain of the cell
What is your body bathing in from
Internal perspective? Well years ago this germ theory when that came out was going against the older theory of terrain theory
Which was cleaning up the environment versus well every diseases caused from a germ
Well, you know what the what science is like when something new is discovered
Well, that's it and all and be all for everything. That's what it was when when the finally the
G-Dome was mapped out that oh my gosh
We're going to find that human genome is so immense that that's what controls everything is our genes
Well, we found out that's not true, right? So
It was the same thing back of the day when germs were discovered when microscopy the degree of ability to magnify something was developed to the point where they could actually see
bacteria
And different microbes that could cause disease well when that was discovered that it was thought that
Microbes cause everything and all diseases caused by microbes
Well, I am not against germ theory understand and I don't think it's germ theory versus terrain theory like many
That's your apathy clinics might be pushing
But we have grown the medical system is completely out of balance and that
Everything is germ theory meaning that it is the microbes that are causing everything if we just killed the microbes
Then we would solve our problem and not realizing we need to clean up the environment
So there's got to be a balance
Louis Pasteur was the person who really pushed germ theory, but interesting on his deathbed his last words were that germ theory is not correct
It's all about the terrain and Antoine Bichelm is the one who was really pushing
The terrain theory to clean up the environment
So it's easy to understand when we have little graphics like this
That if the terrain is very important, but let's not forget we do still need to deal with the microbes
If you have an over abundance of microbes no matter how healthy your terrain is you could get sick. So
We don't want to be too dogmatic there
It's really this soil versus the seed, you know, what causes a
I'm a gardener. I love to garden. I love to grow things
And I have a huge vegetable garden while my wife has this huge flower garden and we are very
Understanding the fact that our soil is everything so we're constantly adding compost and doing things to the soil naturally. We don't use
Chemical fertilizers and certainly we don't use pesticides and herbicides and all that garbage
But working the soil to keep it as pure and clean as possible
Healthy with good microbes and having a
Healthy microbiota of the soil is going to produce the best plants
Um ill soil sick soil is going to produce a sick plant
Because the root is really where it gains its nutrients and where it feeds the rest of the tree or the plant
So that healthy plant is coming from healthy roots
Well, so it is with our body our health our overall health is going to come from
Healthy cells that are feeding off of good nutrients in a healthy environment. It just makes sense if you're listening to this
This is nothing new you guys already understand this
But what we want to dig into here is understanding how we get rid of poisons that we're exposed to
Regardless of how clean we eat and how clean we've made our
Environment where we're not exposing ourselves to poisons and toxins and everything
You are still being exposed to you know, maybe a hundred times more
toxins than our ancestors were
so
That is the key no matter how well you do at you know organic living in one sense
You're still exposed to way more toxins than your ancestors. So
You have to be detoxing
So the truth is is your body is always detoxing and if you're not detoxing
It will be a very short time before you're dead
So your body has different organs of detoxification your major organs are your liver your kidneys your colon
Your skin your lungs how you get rid of poisons that you're exposed to on a moment to moment basis
But let's talk about these phases of detoxification because I think this is really important so important that I wrote a book about it
And normally when you hear about what are the phases of detoxification those are phases of detoxification that are listed in
Physiology books about the liver so you have phase one
liver detoxification pathways that are controlled by certain genes
Phase two that are controlled by other genes those are your congregate conjugation pathways and then phase three
Your pathways where you are creating bile and and bonding the
Conjugated in products to bile to get rid of them out of the body
That's usually where it ends
Well, as I was doing a talk one day. This was several years ago
I would say that's really not where detoxification ends in order as where it starts
So you once you put the end points of phase two into bile that's phase three we'll talk about it in a second
It has to then go through the colon bile duct to the gall bladder and then be excreted into
The first part of the small intestine and then it has to travel through
25 feet of the small intestine and 10 feet of the large intestine to finally be deposited into the toilet
Well all sorts of bad things can happen
Between the liver excreting the bile
Through the common bile duct in it empty into the toilet and that's where we can have major problems
So let's go through some of these quickly and I'll share
this
Stop fighting cancer series more videos about the
Book that I made and also a free download of that book that you could have as well
So the truth is we're all poison no matter how well you take care of yourself no matter how well you eat
Even if you're eating all organic you're still exposed to glyphosate
Other pesticides other herbicides that no matter what there's cross contamination
It's everywhere
So just get over thinking that you are living such a clean life that you're protecting yourself
So phase six so whether I said there's phase one two three that are going out of the liver
Let's go down to the end point first phase six is a limitation and this is a picture of an aloe plant
Because cape aloe is a wonderful
Aid to elimination meeting if you have some constipation problems
Using a little bit of cape aloe can really solve that problem
It can stimulate peristalsis that's the contraction of the muscles that surround the intestinal wall
And it can help draw water into the to the colon similar to magnesium and it can help eliminate it
I'll share a video in in my book in the seven phases of detoxification book
It has a bunch of different products that you could use with this
I don't want to bog down this module with that because I have that in another place
But proper elimination if you're not having at least one model one a day
You're not properly eliminating
So
Believe it or not I've had people say oh yeah, I have good moments normal. I have them every three days
Just like clockwork
Well, you are severely constipated and you are severely poisoning yourself because if you're not getting out
What's on the inside?
You're absorbing that and you are making your body extremely toxic and you want to get cancer then be constipated
So that is the key if you are not eliminated and at least once a day and a good elimination where you're getting everything
Oh, just felt like you ate the day before then you're absorbing all those poisons and you are making yourself very
toxic and very sick
Phase five is binding toxins in the gut binding toxins in the gut
so
Even if you're having a daily bowel movement, did you feel like you're emptying everything out in the gut all the poisons that your liver has gotten rid of
Or hopefully the poisons that you didn't absorb that you were exposed to through your diet
are in the lumen of the intestine so
Technically, they're not inside your body if they're in the lumen of the intestine
So they're in a tube within a tube of your body and you want them to stay in that tube to end up in the toilet
So in order to do that using certain binders can be very beneficial
Here's a benefit of fiber. There's all sorts of different binders that are on the market charcoal and
sodium alginate and we could have a list of a lot of them
but
Using binders can grab onto stuff in the gut and hold it in the gut so you don't reabsorb it
This is a very important phase especially if you have a cancer that is hormonal driven
If you have ER, PR or HER2 positive cancer, you definitely want to be using binded
Agents so that you're grabbing onto hormones because the number one thing that will be reabsorbed in the large intestine will be bad
Astrogens so this is a key component for everybody but it's certainly a key component for
People with hormone positive cancers now understand a lot of the foods you eat have binders
And are binding agents so a lot of the fibers that you eat fiber acts as a binder
It can help you from reabsorbing toxins, but especially if you're dealing with cancer or serious disease
You want to add some binders to your diet as well
Phase four is movie bile so remember I said in phase three bile is created in the liver and bile is a
Fat soluble substance created in the liver that's where your liver
That's what your liver uses to deposit all of the poisons that it filtered out of your blood
It deposits it in the bile so from phase two liver detoxification pathways
It deposits these toxins in to the bile and then the bile flows down your bile duct
And into your common bile duct that part of it came from your pancreas
So now it's the common bile duct and it goes into your gallbladder
If you've had surgery and you've had your gallbladder removed
Well still, bile is flowing down your bile duct, common bile duct, and now directly into your
duodenum the first part of your small intestine
But if you still have your gallbladder, it's flowing then into your gallbladder
Well bile can become quite viscous
Meaning if it becomes thick it can become bulky especially if it's full of a lot of toxins
And even more so if you have other issues like fatty liver disease which is very very common
Or you're exposed to a lot of poisons that heavy metals that your body's dealing with toxins all the time
The common bile duct can become more rigid less flexible
And bile can become very viscous and can flow slowly
That can be a blockage think of your gutters of your house if you had a bunch of leaves in it
And it's not going to allow the water to go out well the gutters are going to overflow right
Well your liver doesn't overflow it just backs up
And then you can't filter things through the blood, through the liver because the liver is stuffed
So helping to move the bile physically can be beneficial
You can take things like things that help produce bile, this will be help for phase 3 also
Globe artichoke can be beneficial
uh
Foss fetidlecolyne can be very beneficial
But what great thing to help with phase 4 is just putting a hot pack over the liver
Also what really helps with this too helps with phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 and phase 6
Is doing coffee edibus. So this is one of the main reasons why you would do coffee edibus
You could help move bile
Neurologically speaking, remember all your cells are controlled by neurons from an electrical
standpoint, neurologically speaking, this is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system
So your parasympathetic nervous system has to do with a made cranial nerve called cranial nerve 10
It's also called your vagus nerve or your vagal nerve
Your vagal nerve also goes down to your rectum
And that's what stimulated when you do coffee edibus
So really the primary purpose of doing coffee edibus is to stimulate the vagus nerve
By stimulating the vagus nerve, you're stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system
By stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system, you're stimulating detoxification
You're helping with phase 1 and phase 2 from a neurological perspective
And you're helping with phase 3 and 4 by getting that bile moving
Also your gallbladder is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system
So anything you can do to stimulate your parasympathetic's the better
Side point, your parasympathetic nervous system
Also controls your immune system
What do you need to fight cancer?
You need an immune system
So the reason why you do coffee edibus is not because you're constipated
You do coffee edibus to stimulate
Cradial nerve tend to stimulate your parasympathetics
To stimulate your immune system
To stimulate your detoxification process
So that's what you need to stimulate healing cancer
So you have to move bile
So doing coffee edibus can help here
Doing a hot pack over the liver can help here
Doing castorial packs over the liver can help you
And I give some other ideas in the book as well
So very important point
Then I clump these together phase 3
Created and binding to bile
We did you're taking the phase 2
Conjugated in products of phase 1
And you're getting it into the bile
Phase 2 is a process called conjugation
That's where the phase 1 in products from the p450 pathways
Then are changed into a less toxic substance
Fat soluble substance or water soluble substances
That are put into the bile so that you can excrete them ultimately in the toilet
So phase 1 and phase 2 are controlled by your parasympathetics
And then genetically by your p450s and your pond 1 pathways
And your multiple other genetic pathways
That's why we do genetic testing honestly
Because we really want to see the health of your of these detoxification pathways
So that we can support them because there are some nutritional pieces that you could use to support them
If you have let's say a lot of defects on your p450s
Or your pond 1 pathways
How can we support those if I have a lot of defects
So I tend to have sluggish phase 2 pathways
So think of it this way
Let's say two people are twin brothers
And they are grew up in the exact same household
But because your twins doesn't mean your genes are the same
Let's say one of the twins has a lot of defects
Other phase 1 and phase 2 pathways
And the other one has less defects
The one that has more defects is going to detoxify things more slowly
So let's say they're both exposed to the same amount of glyphosate
From eating corn in the cob, from their farm that they sprayed with road up
So the one who has less defects will be able to get rid of it much better
Than the one who has more defects
So the one who has more defects that glyphosate is going to stay in their system
Be deposited in the cells
Could end up causing cancer
Months, years, decades down the road
And they can't figure out why they have cancer
Well one of the reasons can be because of the defects
Other phase 1 or phase 2 pathways
That's what we want to look at it
Because if you know prior to getting a serious disease
You can actually support those pathways
And if you know when you have a serious disease supporting those pathways
It can be really important
I know I'm talking really fast
And I apologize that you might have to listen to this twice
But you guys are smart
And you can fly through this stuff
So this isn't anything new
And then phase 0 is detoxifying the tissues
The reason why I listen to this is where everybody wants to start
So they want to start like
Oh my gosh, I'm really toxic and I did this heavy metal test
So I want to go and buy these keylators
Then they're going to pull the toxins out of my body
Well if you don't deal with all these things first
And you are constipated
And you're not binding toxins in the gut
And you are to move in bio very well
And you have sluggish phase 1, phase 2, phase 3 pathways
And you're going to pull stuff out of your tissue
It's got no place to go
And it's just going to circulate
And either make you very sick
Or could even kill you
In a more serious way
Or it most the time
It's going to just circulate somewhere else
And deposit somewhere else
That a healthy thing to do
That's why some people will detox if they'll get sick
It's because they're phase 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1
Are not functioning very well
And they're trying to pull stuff out of the tissue
Not a good idea
Don't do that
So you could do all of this concurrently
But make sure you're doing all of that
You have no business doing the keylation
Somebody that is constipated
If you're a practitioner, listen to this
Make sure you understand that
You have no business
Trying to keylate toxins out of somebody
Who isn't moving their bowel
And you're not addressing
By deed, you're not addressing some other issues
You're going to make the person sicker
So make sure you're aware of that
So the other thing to think of
Is to slow the toxification
We talked about this at the beginning of this module
But starting to learn
To make some better decisions
We have all our patients do this
Now, most people are much more educated than 10 years ago
20 years ago
When I used to teach this stuff 30 years ago
I remember 35 years ago
Having seminars in my office
Trying to explain calcium and vitamin C
Well, you know now with the internet
People are much more educated
There's a lot more information
And I don't have to talk so much about
The regulatory things of health
But making better choices
Just about things that you could be exposed to
Could be some of the simplest things
That you could do that really
Could improve your life
You know, I can't buy all organic
It's too expensive
Or I can't buy all organic
I can't even find it
Just download the Clean 15 Dirty Dozen list
I just got this off the web
And this is from Clean Food Crush
They put this together
A wonderful little infographic
These are your dirty dozen
Are the most sprayed chemically
Induced products on the market
That you could buy
We're all talking about fresh foods and vegetables here
So that's what you should be
Try to stay
That's your first choice
To try to buy fresh foods and vegetables
In the outside of the grocery store
Instead of on the inside of the grocery store
Stay away from that as much as possible
But and then look at the things that are more clean
That you could probably eat
With with less chance of of issues
I don't think I'd recommend that
This list is cord is almost all
Genetically modified
So you want to make sure that that's organic
But you don't need to be so specific on
Ofocados be it organic
Because they're just not very sprayed
Nor are most melons
Very sprayed
But tomatoes are sprayed
Pairs and apples are sprayed
Heavenly strawberries are probably
One of the most toxic
Things out there that are so heavily sprayed
So you want to buy those things organic
So there's just some simple things
To dig into
If you want to really go deep
Then start watching some of the videos
For my cancer genes series
It's a free video series
Different genes that we look for
When a person has cancer
It's not a book
It's actually a video series
That you can get on our website
It's free
Understand all our information is free
I feel like this is a ministry
We're just trying to help people
Learn and take better care of themselves
But this is when you look at different genetics
That we talked about with phase one, phase two pathways
There's a whole bunch of other metabolic pathways
That you look at
When you're trying to help with detoxification pathways
Oxlates and histamines
And all sorts of different stuff
So we can get really deep on that
Simple Simon
Try to look at your clean 15-dirty dozen things
And understand the detoxification pathways
As best as possible
That's going to be your best
Life saver
When you're dealing with a sick
Diagnosis, the cancer diagnosis
So download my book
That will be a best thing for you
The 7 phases of detoxification
And we'll be constantly again
Adding more stuff to this
Stop fighting cancer series
So come back
You'd have to finish all the modules
And see what else we've added
Over time
Trying to make this a very robust
Series with different protocols
That you can follow
And really help take care of yourself
Thank you so much
We'll be praying for you
And we cover
Your prayers for us as well
Bye-bye